the Joe Rogan experience crazy I mean in
retrospect imagine you were were we
let's do a little ranking thing here we
have three vices and I'm I know exactly
where you're gonna be going with this
but we have three things we want to
prioritize dope alcohol [ __ ] smoking
weight cigarettes cigarettes you can ban
one rush to rank them in order you could
start from scratch I'm saying Joe we're
starting over
okay what you say goes rank you weak so
right now the way we have dealt with
these is smoking is is becoming the most
taboo of those three cigarettes mm-hmm
marijuana ii and alcohol is the one that
we have the least inhibitions about
right my argument would be that that
list is exactly backwards that it should
be alcohol should be the most taboo
marijuana should be actually not exactly
backwards it should be alcohol the most
taboo cigarettes the second most
marijuana the third that's how I would
do yeah I would agree with that yeah
yeah so we're basically we have it
completely upside down but I think for
some people like look there's obviously
obviously terrible things that happen to
you when you smoke cigarettes but every
time is it is it pi see I've smoked a
cigarette or two before shows like I've
smoked to say I mean I mean or two I've
never smoked two in a row but I've
smoked a cigarette before I've done
shows like Dave Chappelle gave me one of
his cigarettes recently Tony hinge
cliffs give me a cigarette I'm not a
cigarette smoker but there's something
cool about the head rush that you get
when you smoke a cigarette I hesitate to
say that and this is a person who's done
a lot of drugs I've done a lot I've
smoked a lot of pot and I've done
psychedelics and I'll talk about them
openly
I have hesitation about telling people
that I've enjoyed a cigarette because
because it's because I think it's so bad
for you it's it's it's I think when I
talk about
doing mushrooms I think mushrooms are
good for you I think it makes you freak
out I think it illuminates parts of your
consciousness that I think a lot of
people guard and protect and shield and
I think sometimes doing something that
breaks down those walls is good for you
ultimately overall there's a little bit
of an adjustment period but I think you
learn something about the normal state
of consciousness I don't think you learn
much when you smoke cigarettes I just
think there's just a little bit of a
head rush that you get out of it but I
know so many people that are sick from
cigarettes so many people that can't
quit them so many people that have died
from cancer I mean I personally have
known several people that have died from
cancer from smoking cigarettes yeah so I
hesitate in saying it but I don't want
to be dishonest I've had them yeah I
don't smoke cigarettes though I've never
bought a pack I've that's a cigar of
smoke cigars I like um sometimes I just
think it's a terrible it's a terrible
thing to get hooked on yeah yeah and as
I would say the same thing with alcohol
I know people that have had real
problems with alcohol that have been
alcoholics and they have to go to
meetings and you know they're on 12-step
programs and you know I would never
offer them a drink mm-hmm but if you
said hey let's do a shot right now let's
celebrate we this is a wonderful
conversation let's have a glass of
whiskey I can have a glass of whiskey
and not drink again
it doesn't bother me oh yeah I don't I
don't have that whatever that is yeah
but some people do yeah I hesitate
hesitating glorifying that - yeah and
for young people it scares the [ __ ] out
of me if I see I probably drank for the
first time when I was probably I was in
high school I think is probably 14 or 15
first time I ever got drunk with my
friends you know we got a hold of some
Jack Daniels or something and made me
throw us the I smell drinking age yes
well you know it's just friends you know
listen in the classic rock and getting
drunk in fosston but the it's it's
something I occasionally enjoy I think I
enjoy alcohol I like having a drink of
wine with a glass of wine with a meal I
like having a drink with friends
occasionally but I don't have a problem
with it and I know people who do
and so I feel weird talking about it
knowing those people that do have a
problem with it yeah yeah with pot
though the people that have a problem
with pot it's rare and it's usually
people that have some sort of and I do
believe there there is an issue with
people have some sort of an underlying
schizophrenic issue that could come from
especially high doses if they smoke a
lot of pot in one night they can have a
schizophrenic episode I've actually seen
it particularly from edibles I've seen
it but that's to me that's absolutely
the least taboo and I think there's a
lot of benefits to pot I think pot makes
you more sociable I think it makes you
friendlier I mean some people get
paranoid from it but I think that's what
that really is is marijuana illuminating
how vulnerable you actually are yeah you
know that we sort of protect ourselves
from this overwhelming existential angst
that you get when you get high on pot
yeah and people say oh I don't like it
it makes me paranoid well you know the
reality is you're vulnerable we're all
very very very vulnerable and we just
somehow another make it to like how old
are you fifty-six I'm fifty two we made
it we made this age somehow or another
despite all the paranoia we don't have
to I mean it's really you know life is
crazy we're in these metal boxes with
combustion engines
you know like trusting the people next
to us going 60 miles an hour paying
attention not looking at their phone you
know it's like it's very in then we get
in planes and who else the [ __ ] going
on with the engine this guy's flying it
over the sky it's we're very vulnerable
all the time just diseases and you know
not to mention you know war and all
sorts of other things that could float
weight away yeah I mention everything
earthquake fire yeah yeah fires yes no
my my thing on this is simply the
collateral damage yeah
there so leave the individual out of it
and ask how much social damage is caused
by any of those things
okay in alcohol and that number one just
by a bullet yeah yeah you know what's
amazing to me is how the people who make
alcohol
have to get a free ride it's incredible
to me like if I said to you that I was
on the board of Philip Morris you would
say that's Malcolm that's pretty screwed
up yeah and you would you would be you
know a problem with it if I said that oh
I'm you know I'm on the board of
anheuser-busch you probably would hit me
up for tickets to the Super Bowl
mmm right is that the same whereas
there's no in terms of the amount of
social damage what out what
anheuser-busch has created has produced
a hundred times the social damage than
what Philip Morris has produced Yeah
right like or you know so it's like it's
a it's always puzzled about I don't know
how he got it in our heads like to treat
one like it's completely taboo and the
other we kind of shrug you know the
there are a bunch I was reading about
this recently how many colleges except
not just accept alcohol advertising and
sponsorship but you go to a college
football game and you know Bud Light
will have will be an active sponsor of
the event will have some huge
relationship with the school this is
crazy I mean it's crazy right it's like
this is the drug that is causing so many
problems for young people particularly
on campuses and the schools are hand in
glove with the manufacturers of it
because it's socially acceptable because
they don't have to worry about
repercussions because we gave it up in a
way that they would never have Marlboro
Marlboro yeah oh my god people would
pick it yeah where is it's not you know
I don't know that's true too strange
kind of we're so messy people are so
messy and that is that's a very good
example of how messy we are
[Applause]